that's what was here law Nativity it's
the highlight of the week a poetry
reading in the hit SATs refugee camp in
northern Ethiopia close to the border
with Eritrea $1 T ferry is a regular
here it gives him and the other refugees
like him Direction hope and helps pass
the time today his poem is about mothers
there are more than 10,000 people
stranded in hit sets well might uh with
me I'd thought about an idea and I might
I wrote this poem because each of us has
left the mother behind I want to say
there's no need to feel stressed or
afraid because we all share the same
story I want to offer them courage Eddie
I told us has been in hits us for four
years now he and his wife were married
in Eritrea a year before they fled the
country they were young and just
starting out their life together but
that seemed impossible in Eritrea the
government is one of the harshest
dictatorships in Africa many Africans
fleeing to Europe
come from there
I miss my family terribly but we
couldn't do anything else aside from the
political circumstances the economic
situation is tough to $1 and his wife
are hoping that international refugee
organizations will help them move to
another country they can't afford to pay
smugglers to get them across the
Mediterranean and you could see visio
gonna be wouldn't we just hope we'll be
able to leave this camp one day only a
few people have been transferred to
other countries since we arrived four
years ago according to the rules of the
refugee relief organizations this
process should only take 12 months but
it seems to be a question of luck I'm
still hopeful but I have no idea
when it will be our turn here in
Ethiopia refugees are not allowed to
work that's led many to despair some
have even committed suicide and today
and each day more people among them are
many miners as well as those who already
have family in Europe I have no idea
what will happen next
it's up to my husband to sort things out
for us in Germany he told me to take the
children to Ethiopia everything else is
up to him but refugee aid organizations
often have to step in they're
overwhelmed by the numbers of people
arriving increasing numbers of migrants
are heading off trying to make it to
Europe with the help of people smugglers
they say they know it's dangerous but
they'll do anything to get out of the
camp
we are creating awareness for these
refugees to stay here but they need some
livelihood activities in the camps they
don't have any opportunity to stay here
and they're preparing to go to them
because they want to lead their life I
don't have an ID Ollis plays music to
quell his frustration he says he doesn't
mind if he and his wife end up in the US
Europe or Ethiopia he just wants to be
able to work and take control of his own
destiny